you're on set when was it was it day one
where
i'm just gonna be the voice of ben
mckenzie's mind like there was a show
called inside herman's head where you
could hear all the voices
i loved that show now when you saw
morena the first time
was the inside voice going holy all
right
she's beautiful or did it take sort of
time before you guys
was it very professional was it very i'm
sure it was professional
you're professional but when was the
moment where you're like
huh i can't get her out of my head or
she can't get you out of here
i don't know when that happened exactly
i do remember the first time i saw her
which was
um she
she was cast very quickly in the middle
of the first season because
the construction of the show was that i
was supposed to be with barbara keane
james growing up with barbara keane all
the fanboys out there like yeah of
course we know all about this um
but it was weird it just didn't quite it
didn't quite work because they'd set
up barbara to be this uh
rich girl who lived in you know
penthouse in gotham city and but gordon
was supposed to be the everyman and
it just didn't quite have the the
romantic pop
and pop yeah and it was through no fault
of aaron richards playing the character
and they ultimately did what they should
have done which is
turned far right into a villain
and that's where she went and that's
that that tension sort of under
uh underlay their relationship moving
forward but they needed a new a new
object of affection and and a real
romance that could sort of like
underpin the the show from from a a
romantic standpoint so so she was cast
i remember it was like october yeah i
remember what day it was exactly it was
october 22nd
and for reasons that will become clear
soon and it was
raining it was a miserable day we were
shooting in like some pretty rough area
of the bronx i want to say
raining cats and dogs we were inside uh
thankfully but
she showed up for uh makeup and hair
tests and and maybe some camera tests um
because she was going to shoot
the next week for some reason they
needed her that day in order to get
everything right
and i was filming some other stuff and
the basically the the executive producer
inspired she he told me that she wanted
to meet me and talk to me and he told
her
that i wanted to talk to her anyway
i was in my trailer and i got a knock on
the door
and i opened it up and she's standing
there in the rain
and normally you would think like oh
romantic like but instead it was just
this
drenched rain she looked like
something was wrong something was
clearly wrong
and i was like i mean
other than just her being soaked and i
was like i'll come in
and come in come in and we had a little
small talk but slowly there's something
going on
you know you don't mind me asking like
are you okay and she was like yeah yeah
yeah yeah and she did that thing on
marina you know tough tough morning
yeah no i'm fine fine fine i'm fine fine
fine you're like what happened like my
mom died or something
like whoa okay no she would no no no i'm
sorry i know
since her mom is alive and alive and
well yeah you're a saturday night
in brazil uh she she goes yeah no it's
just
it's my son's birthday today and i was
like
oh oh my god that you you flew out on
your son's birth oh my god yeah they're
like they needed me today
and then i was like oh man i'm so sorry
how old is he and i'm thinking
i'm like assuming he's like of a certain
age and even though she's very young i'm
like
she's like he's one i was like
i'm sorry you missed your son's first
birthday because you had to be here
why did you say that ben but you're
rubbing it no no i know i know no no not
not out
like i can't believe that you know do
that no offense like of course
i mean warner brothers god love you like
seriously you couldn't let her have a
day
and she's really heartbroken by it and
she she she had
she went back to uh she flew out that
night to go back to be with him for
there for his party
but it was this like very human moment
it was just a very human moment so
that's how it started was
it didn't nothing started but it started
with she's a human being i'm a human
being
she she she is actually in deep
discomfort
but sucking it up to do a job which i
thought was like
you know both sort of tragic but also
commendable right like she's
she's she's doing what she has to do to
to
to to do her thing um so yeah that's how
that sounds i don't remember the exact
you know ins and outs of the rest of it